oh hello everybody hi ah welcome back to
let's play gray now we're in this
hallway I don't know what I'm doing some
of you oh yeah that's right Oh duh no
wait um what do you guys wrote a message
that the arrow on the the thingy might
have said that it was supposed to be
backwards which is six oh two five six
haha ping pong ha ha ha hey that oh yeah
oh thank you whoever said that because
then I know I know just be be me away
Stucky like ten billion hours wait a
minute wait a minute there's nothing
here what this no that can't be right
keep your right there's nothing chicer
oh oh no no no no no no no no no what
what was it pointed break you boxes oh
come on this is just a doll really I
probably got every single one of those
dolls by now jeez okay there's a door at
the end of the hallway that's supposed
to be open by another means blue enemies
yeah break it down with them good glad
they have plenty of bullets that's good
right shut up music ah let me through
that's not how glass is supposed to be
hit alright
oh man I don't know okay it's gotta be
one of these rooms maybe one of these
doors is ratable I'm just gonna try
everyone well look procedurally in every
room
[Music]
all right I kept door you know you
quickie wood that's just the thing the
Lisa the other thing
ah God I don't like you I don't like any
of you okay
not in there miss adore ah baby locked
dang it hey dude
shut up music oh what is that buzzes
what's that where's this Oh hon door
control how did I miss your control ah
you gotta be ah mrs. ah some sort of
combination I'm gonna put in force
this is no memorable about the things
and stuff Oh bad dog hmm
Bing bong Bing bong Bing bong I get it
get the door please tell me that got the
door shut up music alright please go
sleepy I'll please be open tell man
we'll be back
I hope I can fight this guy
why do I not boom Wow where Oh
buy me try me
ah the loser ha ha ha you look pretty
stupid with all those balls in your head
ah hating and my flashlight is not
helping at all
needs more battery
Ellen this is a suspicious hallway
suspicious
oh-oh-oh don't like this
my little Anita go oh boy I'm sorry no
you didn't what did you do Oh
ha ha ha ah come on
[Applause]
she's darling darling you're safe Nassif
now you're saying you see everything is
going to go what they owe her my melee
swings are through the roof
what did those it Wow ah what ah you
gotta be kidding me
that's the ending ah ah hell really I
just get trapped in that's the ending a
stick dragon or sim tangen huh huh man
only ending that Vlad was incredible I
mean to have an amazing atmosphere kind
of wondering if there's something else I
missed - probably in skies if there's
something that I missed
let me know in the comments and I'll
come back to it because I'm pretty sure
there must be something else there I
know these guys these guys are kind of
the same similar team that may cry for
some people been saying so if it is then
that means that they put multiple
endings in there so hopefully hopefully
there's something else please let me
know in the comments and also let me
know what you thought
to begin with I don't know what the hell
is going on the guy was just batshit
insane but hey it was a great game that
there's more to there's another
difficulty so maybe there's something in
the other difficulty that might be true
but I guess I said I'm gonna kind of
wait until the end of it
interesting I didn't know how that
closely read my first last episode but
I'll be somewhat of credit there's um
hardcore mode and challenge maps has
been unlocked to the main menu play
hardcore for new enemies modified maps
and new ending a new ending and much
more ah-ha-ha-ha-ha
man normal mode was hard enough what
makes them think I can actually do
hardcore mode okay I'm not sure if I'm
gonna do a whole nother let's play of
hardcore mode but unless there's
considerably different content unless
there's like outstandingly different I
probably won't go back then they'd love
to play through till I get the ending
but then again I don't have a lot of
time to just do that so let me know let
me know let me know what you guys want
me to do so but for now thank you all so
much for watching and as always see you
in the next video but I